[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
موزه انا موزه
احملوا للصحه كنزه
منعشه
وشهيه
وبالالياف غنيه
موزه موزه انا موزه موزه احملوا للصحه
كنزه كنزه
نوار شهيه شهيه وبالايام
[موسيقى]
مرزه موزه موزه انا موزه
موزه موزه موزه انا موزه
موزه موزه موزه انا موزه هيا قلني
اعطيك الطاقه تنشط تلعب بلايا بلايا
وساجعل قلبك اقوى كي تتمتع برشاقه
موزه موزه موزه انا موزه
موزه موزه موزه انا موزه انا غنيه
بالسعرات احوي ايضا
فيتامينا هي معادن
ومغذيات انفع بين التمر
موزه موزه انا موزه موزه احمل للصحه كنزه
كنزه معيشه نوار شهيه شهيه
وبالالياف غنيه انا انفع جدا للهضم فالموز
للمعده
مهمتك لتكبر من اكلي
واحده تكفي باليوم موزه موزه موزه انا
موزه
موزه موزه موزه انا موزه